hello and welcome everyone to pi data
global 2021
i
would now like to welcome
seth shalnut to our session he will talk
about extending jupiter data
visualizations beyond the
notebook
seth is chief technology officer of tile
db inc where he works to expand and
support open source initiatives
and the company's main product tile ddb
db cloud
seth earned his bachelor of science in
statistics at the university of florida
and he builds
systems from massive data handling and
manipulation
seth is a regular contributor to open
source software and he's worked on
developing a new custom storage engine
for mariadb jupiter lab integrations and
distributed computation integrations
with spark and presto db
so with that i'll i'll uh
turn over the screen to you seth welcome
thank you jennifer thank you for the
lovely introduction and i'd like to just
go ahead and thank you for all the work
that you've done and everyone else has
done for the pi data global conference
you know we're on the last day today and
it's been a wonderful conference so far
uh and hopefully everyone finds my
presentation today to uh to go along
with everything that's been talked about
at the conference
for the presentation i'm going to start
with some slides and then i will go into
a live demo for the second half talking
about specifically and showing some of
the visualization work that we have done
here
so i'm sure jupiter doesn't need much of
an introduction for everyone here at pi
data
but just a quick recap of some of the
highlights of jupiter and why we are
very interested in it
it's pretty much the de facto standard
for interactive data exploration
analysis and sharing
everybody is very familiar with jupiter
there's a lot of work that data science
goes on around jupiter and a lot of
development has happened the last couple
years
to make it very very much the standard
for data science community
interactivity usually means rendering
some uh form of output in some form one
of the nice things about jupiter is that
you have a web browser and you can
render things a lot nicer than on
command line so this could be as simple
as tables you know panda's data frame
being outputted in a way that you can
view it
rendering images of course
maps three dimensional renderings really
anything's the lim sky's the limit here
with what can be done
and it's important to note too that
jupyter notebooks extend just beyond
python of course they're ubiquitous in
the python ecosystem
but there's kernels in many languages
are julia javascript and more and we see
the community continuing to grow
in the use of jupiter even outside the
python ecosystem
um
i think we've had a lot of talks
this past couple days about jupiter and
the use in production jupiter is not
just for exploration but a lot of people
take it all the way to production uses
whether this is in
you know end user dashboards or
data exploration machine learning models
there's tons and tons of use that people
use for the jupyter notebooks
and specifically i like to even shout
out
voila plug-in which can enable web style
dashboards to really show some of the
flexibility that you have with the
jupiter environment
so
to understand a little bit why we are
interested in jupiter why the title db
as a company has invested resources i
want to spend just a brief moment
explaining what we are what we do and
where our customers really come in to
see some of the advantages of jupiter
so tile db first and foremost is data
stored in a universal analysis ready
format the key foundation of this is a
multi-dimensional array format that we
have created
and this works directly with the
universal data management platform that
we've created around tiled cloud it
gives you secure governance and
collaboration scalable serverless
compute data and code sharing and
monetization enabled first and foremost
with jupiter notebooks that we'll talk
about today
and our cloud
sas services all as a pay-as-you-go
manner specifically where the consumer
is the one that pays which works really
well with the dashboard functionality
we'll talk about at the end of the
presentation
now it's important to note too that
title db
is designed to work from one user with
any tool
at any scale extreme interoperability
all the way up to entire organizations
so
we're very interested in jupiter not
just for its python ecosystem but as i
mentioned julia r javascript and many
other languages because we work really
hard to have extreme interoperability of
the data with whatever platform and
tooling that the end user is interested
in
so the secret sauce is
the multi-dimensional array that we
mentioned so tile db fundamentally
stores data in a multi-dimensional array
format this can be either dense arrays
or sparse arrays a dense is simply where
every single cell has a value think an
image
or a video where every single pixel is
going to be filled in a sparse array is
something where there could be missing
values that are not materialized on disk
think of location data where you have
lat longs but you're not covering the
entire globe
or think of tabular data
with a primary key that might not
have every cell filled in time series is
a good example of that where you often
have
missing values
but the foundation of all of this
enables you to store any type of data in
tile db format
which directly comes to the the place
where you want to analyze any data
so how do we build all of this together
and where does jupiter fit into
everything so first and foremost it's
important to understand that tile to be
works on any back end
this could be
aws s3 this could be azure blob store
this could be a local file system this
could even be ram
but we have integrations in a variety of
languages
and tooling so we have seven different
apis in different languages we have
integrations with jupyter which we're
talking about we have integrations with
mariedb domain specific tools like
poodle judo hail
and pandas
and all of this is built upon our
entirely embedded storage engine which
is completely open source and open spec
open format available right on github
today
provides highly parallel i o rapid reads
and writes we'll talk a little bit about
how the reads and writes come into play
specifically with jupiter
it's columnar and cloud optimized and we
support data versioning and time
traveling in the base format which also
will come come into play in just a
moment here
on top of the embedded library we have
also built out titled cloud which is our
hosted sas offering which allows for the
unified data management and easily
scaling to global scale for access
control logging or serverless
computations around sql uds task graphs
and of course interactive visualizations
with notebook plugins and dashboards
of course all of our apis and
integrations work with the embedded
library and tile to be cloud which we'll
talk about in just a moment when we look
at some of the r work we've done around
jupiter
so
again why is title db interested in
jupiter and where do we really see
everything fitting together well most of
our users whether they're community
users or customers are scaling are
storing large amounts of data in a
highly scalable and highly sliceable
format tile db
interactive visualizations and rendering
is very important for exploration and
analysis it's all great if we can store
large amounts of data but people of
course need to access that data and do
something with it and interactive
visualizations is critical for the
exploration and analysis of data
workloads these days
often data scientists also want to
produce some sort of report
or dashboard for end user consumptions
not everyone that will consume data is
at the level where they are comfortable
writing python r or other uh code
and many times they're just looking for
an end user style dashboard whether
that's a map rendering whether that's
just a tabular report
but something for the end user to
consume
so we've taken a lot of the lessons
we've learned from the community and our
customers and produced several plugins
which we'll talk about today we have a
large number of plugins but i've chosen
four to highlight for the talk today the
first is a content plugin where we
actually store
uh jupyter notebooks as tiled to be
arrays so we talked a brief bit about
the format and some of the features and
we'll talk specifically how that works
with our content plug-in
in just a moment
we also have really great plug-in that
allows you to have our shiny dashboards
rendered directly in jupyter
lab and jupiter hub itself
um we've taken the babylon js 3d
rendering engine from javascript and
written a plug-in that allows you to do
some nice visualizations
we've also worked on extending the
mapbox jupyter plug-in for additional
mapping support and integration with our
our vector tile server to have some very
nice map renderings
so let's start off talking a little bit
about the content plug-in
so jupyter provides a nice content api
for those that aren't familiar that
allows you to have plugable back-end
storage most people just use the the
file storage back-end but there's a
couple plugins that are popular out
there one for using s3
as a file system
another one for storing your your
notebooks and postgres but we've
specifically written a plugin that
allows you to store your data in the
tile to be format
um and entirely be raised and so we
store it as a one-dimensional dense tile
db array
and we inherit all the functionality of
the title of the arrays so you can
effectively store it on the remote blob
store uh it's cloud cloud native so
azure
uh s3 google cloud wherever you'd like
to store it it can be stored and
accessed directly no need to download
that notebook you can simply slice
right from the cloud into your notebook
the time traveling support is native so
this allows you to see all revisions of
a notebook
this means as soon as you create the
notebook the history is saved uh
and every time you write to the array
title db has again it's a cloud native
format we have we every write performs
an immutable write so new rights uh go
to new directories this allows you to
time travel and so we'll show a little
bit about this uh in the demo but this
is very powerful as you're building out
your notebook and you're linking it to
other users you can guarantee that
they're always going to see the right
version of the notebook and allows you
to go back and forth maybe the notebook
worked yesterday you've made some
changes it doesn't work today we've all
been in that situation uh so it's very
easy to go back and see exactly what
your code was like yesterday
and of course integrating into the title
to be cloud you get access control auto
logging and all the collaboration
features of tile to be cloud
so the integration of course is
available on github today anyone can
download it you can install it you can
use it today
and you can you can start storing your
arrays we'll talk a little bit about
how this all works in the demo showing
you some of that time traveling support
um then
the the next plugin that we have is
for our shiny and
not everyone might be familiar with our
shiny especially those that are
predominantly in the python ecosystem
but but our shinee is a
shiny as in our package that makes it
easy to build interactive web apps
straight from our
it's created by our studio i mean it's
very very popular in the art community
everyone loves to write their web apps
right here you can very simply uh
use it much like jupiter provides a
variety of
um ipi widgets and things for
interactivity our shiny has a lot of
integrations there integration with
bootstrap and different frameworks so
you can produce very nice visualizations
um with a few lines of our code
most
people that build shiny apps are
building specifically for data
exploration or visualization so allowing
users to have an interactive web
interface to explore the data themselves
or to do some sort of visualization
the shiny works by running its own web
server by default so it spins up a web
server and a port and people access that
directly there is a lot of overlap in
the use cases around shiny and jupiter
however we rarely see people crossing
the uh the ecosystems between shiny and
jupiter and we believe a lot of this is
because there has not been sufficient
integration between the two you can
write our
shiny apps you can write jupiter
notebooks there hasn't been a lot of
work to to uh link the two together um
until we've uh we've released some some
software now that we'll talk about to
facilitate that
so we built what we call the shiny
background manager
shiny background manager or shiny bg is
an extension to shiny which provides two
key features that enable the
collaboration
managing multiple shiny applications in
a single process
and integration with the ir kernel for
displaying shiny directly in jupiter
we really wanted to facilitate those
that are in the r ecosystem to be able
to explore and use jupiter people are
very comfortable building out shiny apps
so we wanted to allow those same users
to be involved in the jupiter ecosystem
as we said the jupiter ecosystem is
continuing to grow quite drastically
and a lot of our users like to program
in different languages one group might
be in python one group might be an r
another one in julia all in the same
organization and we want to facilitate
them having a common understanding and a
common uh
framework for data exploration
so once again this is available right
now on github
we are pushing it to crayon relatively
soon but you can install it right from
github today
so let's talk a little bit of a deep
dive into how we facilitate this because
we've done quite a bit of work in order
to connect the dots here to allow a
seamless integration between shiny and
jupiter the first is managing multiple
shiny applications in a single process
so
shiny typically runs on either a random
port or user-defined port with that web
server so every time you spin up a shiny
app usually it grabs a random open port
from the system or the user defines it
but the port need to be coordinated if
of course if there's multiple shiny apps
running concurrently and we need to keep
track of
you know which app is using which port
and where's the web server running so
that we can use that information in
jupyter to iframe directly into the
environment so it's very important that
we have the ability to manage multiple
shiny apps all in the same process
shiny also typically is a it blocks the
main the main thread or the main process
much like
python r is
typically run in a single threaded mode
it has a similar interpreter lock like
python so usually when you run shiny
you're going to block however that's not
the ideal experience for jupiter right
it's jupiter is an interactive
experience you typically want to launch
one cell and be able to move to the next
one especially with rendering and output
people kind of expect to be able to have
multiple things happening so we need to
be able to launch it in the background
also if we're going to launch in the
background we need to be able to stop it
right if uh if it's running in the
background we want to stop that notebook
and
sorry stop that kernel and stop the
shiny app when the kernel goes down or
the notebook shuts down prevent any
leakage that could happen
so
in addition to just managing all of the
uh
all of the shiny apps we also need to
have integration on the rendering side
of the house
so
we do this via an iframe
because again shiny is running its own
web server local to your the environment
so we can simply iframe into it
thankfully the ir kernel has the ability
to display raw html so we're able to
write a couple snippets of code uh
to pass the ir kernel um
the html for iframing out whatever the
the shiny server is running on
we support iframing either to jupiter
hub or local local jupiter instances so
we're able to detect if a proxy is
needed um similar to a lot of uh python
based applications that require a port
forwarding a proxy
all the shiny server information is
passed in directly from that manager so
again as we're managing multiple shiny
instances when you want to render one we
have the ability to we have all that
information to pass directly in um to
the the ir kernel side of the house
all right we'll we'll show a little bit
example of the shiny plug-in
when we get to the demo um
but i also want to briefly mention our
babylon js plug-in that we have so
babylon js is a real-time 3d engine
using javascript for displaying 3d
graphics in a web browser with html5
this is currently predominantly
built by microsoft
it was not originally microsoft project
but they have they are
predominantly the the main users and
developers of it today
and we've written a plugin that allows
you to pass python data directly to
babylon.js for 3d rendering so this
makes it very very powerful to
get data in python but produce those 3d
visualizations that a lot of people uh
like to do these days especially html5
full interactivity is supported entire
scenes can be rendered and live updated
on the pi from from python so if you
want to render
part of a frame um whatever maybe is in
the viewport and then as the user pans
and zooms add in you know from the
python side fetch the new data pass it
in and render it live all of that is
possible with the plugin that we've
created
we use it today predominantly for lidar
renderings so this makes it very easy
for us to take lidar data stored in the
tile to be format and render it directly
through babylon js for output most lidar
users really like to see the rendering
of what's happening and once again we
have full interactivity around panning
and zooming which makes it very easy to
slice
parts of the data pass it into the
notebook without maybe
rendering the entire frame especially if
the frames you know
especially if the lidar data is you know
100 gigabytes in size we can slice just
you know a 10 20 megabyte section render
it in the browser
and dynamically update it as the user
zooms around in the environment
uh once again this is all available on
github
um and installable today
so the last thing that i want to cover
before we move to the live demo is the
work that we've done around the mapbox
gl um plugin for jupiter so mapbox
already has an existing plugin for
jupiter it was developed for display
displaying 2d maps inside jupiter um it
but it only supports a subset of the
mapbox gl javascript functionality um
it's written very well but we wanted to
extend it to support a couple of key
features that we that we use with tile
db specifically
such as 2d vector tiles
so tile db offers a native 2d vector
tile server we can store 2d tile we can
store the the data in
the tile db format um and then via tile
to be cloud we can actually serve the 2d
vector tiles natively
so this allows anyone to render
two-dimensional map data against tile db
wherever a compatible client exists so
it could be you know in the web browser
it could be with the mapbox gl jupyter
plug-in right here
um
and of course
uh jupiter is just a very natural fit
for users to map their data and to
render those 3d maps especially when you
consider using vola
to render that map without needing a web
server so you can have jupyter running
in a common environment you can render
the output and with villa you can have
that in a very very nice dashboard form
very very easy for anyone to set up
without needing any infrastructure there
um currently most of our changes are
available in a fork that we've made but
we're working to upstream it soon we're
we're talking with the uh the mapbox gl
group and we'll be upstreaming some of
our improvements in the near future
all right with that i'd like to stop my
presentation and spend the the last few
minutes uh showing an actual demo of
some of the the features here
so first and foremost is i want to show
the content plugin that we have in
jupyter so
there's a couple important things that
uh that i mentioned about our content
plugin and the first is that you're able
to store these notebooks directly on the
cloud without having to have them
locally so we can see right here in the
web interface um i'm using jupyter lab
uh in our hosted environment on tile to
be cloud which makes it very simple all
the plugins are pre-installed for you
and everything but the jupiter lab i'm
using is pretty much the jupiter lab
that anyone uh
anyone that's attended pi data is
familiar with with all the content
plugin with all the plugins that i've
just talked about pre-installed
but here we can see i've got my pi data
notebook already open and running and we
can see my file browser on the left-hand
side and specifically everything's
underneath this cloud folder
for everything that i own underneath the
entirely organization a typical
hierarchy similar to like github style
repositories that we use entitled to be
cloud
for managing where all of your data is
stored
but if i switch to the terminal real
quick
we can see that if i list there is no
cloud
sorry there is a cloud folder but
there's nothing here
so we can go to tiles of ink and it's
completely empty this is because all of
the
um
files that we see in the left-hand side
are not stored locally in the notebook
itself instead they're all stored
remotely
on s3 and they're accessed directly from
s3 so we don't actually need to have the
files in my local environment so this is
again super super powerful to be able to
have all of the data remotely
and access it
and slice and dice it right there so
this makes the collaboration very easy
now i also have a a section here on time
traveling and as i mentioned we have
direct integration with the the
checkpoint system that jupiter has
itself so you can use the checkpoints to
go back and forth but even more powerful
than the checkpoints is the fact that
the data for the notebook is stored
natively in tile db with the time
traveling built in so not only in
jupiter itself can you access the data
and time travel but outside of it you
can too
so we have a we have a nice uh interface
that we've written here in our ui to
access the tile db cloud notebooks
and to render them uh in a static manner
here some of how like github does static
rendering
and so we can view the preview and
everything but one of the the features
that i really want to talk about is we
have the the version in here currently
we're in the latest version of the
notebook but if i click it we can see
all the different versions from every
time that i've saved this notebook um
here and specifically if we go back to
uh to the the 147 uh utc time um we can
see that the notebook's actually changed
right i didn't have my section on time
traveling uh quite written at that point
so i've added it in the latest one but
this makes it very very easy uh to look
at the notebook the preview to see what
it was like before
to go back and forth between different
versions of the notebook and of course
you can link out to directly to this
notebook so via tile db cloud again
we include the timestamp and the details
right in the url so you can share this
specifically with individuals
and know that you know they're going to
see a static version of that and if i
click launch i could actually go
directly into jupyter lab that would
take me directly into jupiter lab where
would it we would actually see this
version of the notebook again using the
checkpoint system it's very easy in
jupiter lab to go between different
runnable versions of that notebook
so this this functionality again is all
empowered by tile db
arrays underneath that natively support
such time traveling capabilities
all right um if we go back to the
notebook
one of the main things that i want to
highlight too is our r shiny dashboard
and i know we're starting to run low on
time so i'm going to move through these
uh a little bit faster uh to save room
for any questions that might show up at
the end but the shiny dashboards are one
of the the main features that we feel
very very uh strongly about that we've
added here so of course the shiny is
over in the r ecosystem so i've created
two separate uh notebooks that are our
notebooks um to to show this the first
is uh the the 101 shiny example the most
basic example you can get right from the
the shiny website um to render the uh
the old faithful geyser data
so simply i import the shiny library and
i import the shiny background library as
we mentioned i built the shiny app just
like you normally would so this is
straight up copy paste it from the basic
tutorial and shiny the main difference
is i'm going to call render the shiny
app here and when i do that
we're going to get the live interactive
r
shiny dashboard embed it right here so
this is full interactive everything
works
and you can simply use it for any type
of shiny dashboard you'd like for any
complexity um again
this is all proper shiny code the only
difference is the command to run it i
call the render command from from r
which does everything we've talked about
launches the the shiny uh dashboard with
a particular port
um managing all the different ports that
are available on the system
it stores all that information it then
checks to see what um
you know what environment are you in in
this case we actually are running
through jupiter hub so it detects that
it needs to use the proxy plug-in and
everything uh and then presents the
iframe uh directly here for that so it's
all managed
for you um right here now of course this
is a pretty basic example you can get
pretty fancy with uh with uh the shiny
world so uh we have another example
where we've actually um
created the shiny app as a separate
github repository because this is a
quite verbose application so you can
store it anywhere you'd like we simply
install it in the environment using the
the remote's installed github
for those that are more python centric
this is a similar to a pip style install
but can install packages right from
right from github
um next we we once again we import the
you know the shiny background i call the
library that i have which is already
preset up i render the shiny app and
you can of course have full support for
a variety of things including if you do
want to specify the port manually a lot
of flexibility there
and then we have a full uh a full
interactive shiny app here with you know
multiple tabs details we can run queries
this is actually querying a title db
array behind the scenes getting tabular
output
printing um
you know plots of the data here so any
type of shiny dashboard uh can be used
directly in jupiter with the plugin that
we've created here
all right going back to the python world
the last two things that i'm going to
highlight real quick is the babylon js
plugin that we have so i have a title of
the array that stores lidar data for
boulder colorado
we're going to open the data and we're
going to we're going to get the data
back
in numpy in a numpy uh
dictionary so i'm just gonna slice a
particular region of uh this lidar data
set that's the front of one building i
i've predetermined what the front of
this is
then i'm going to uh convert the data to
the dictionary that babylon js needs and
specifically i'm going to colorize it by
changing the red green blue to the scale
that babylon js expects
then we will create an instance of it i
will set my zoom level and render it
live
and so this again will run fetch the
data passes it directly into babylon js
and then produces the the 3d output here
it's fully interactive you can scale you
can zoom you can move it all around so
sky is really the limit on what you can
do with babylon js and like i say you
can also update the values with however
you'd like and get live updates of the
rendering
so the last item is our integration with
the mapbox vector tile server so i'm
going to access a particular data set
here that is the climate research unit
from the united kingdom that has
worldwide temperature data for several
years
um i'm going to have a map box api that
i've stored i'm going to of course
center this on boston massachusetts and
that that's where i'm located i'm just
going to pick a single month uh for
simplicity that'll show some nice uh
differences on the map
um and then i'll just use the mapbox
api calling the raster tiles passing in
a couple parameters including zoom level
and we can render it live here and of
course you know sky's the limit on what
you can do
rendering everything live right in the
environment full map is supported
of course all of this that we've
mentioned can be used with the vola
plug-in so for instance we do have the
ability to render that with vala so
here's that same r dashboard directly in
the interface without any code
with the same the same level of
interactivity that you would expect so
we have a lot a lot of flexibility with
the plugins that we've created we're
very happy to be working a lot on open
source software and to promote the
jupiter ecosystem to help explore the
data visualization
to access the large data store entiredb
and have it right here in the
environment for anyone to uh to access
and render
like i mentioned everything that i have
here is open source available right on
tiled to be cloud uh we'll also provide
links um to the plugins and to the um
to the presentation um in the chat after
this call uh i'm very happy to jennifer
and everyone for pi data for for hosting
us today so thank you for the time
thanks so much for the demo very
interesting to see
so with that i'll uh stop this recording
thanks so much for participating
thank you